foreign
[Music]
OLED has seen a few iterations in its
lineup with its latest and newest
edition being the ux 5304 that we have
right here now not only is this probably
one of the cleanest and fastest Ultra
books you can get your hands on right
now but it's also the world's slimmest
OLED Ultra portable laptop in the market
offering impressive performance and
premium design now with that in mind
let's run you through the s13s features
but before we get into it this channel
is supported by Brands who help us
improve our content and keep us going so
stay around for this sponsored message
if you are looking for a laptop that
does it all gaming streaming and content
creation then look no further than the
Rog surface M16 the first 16 inch laptop
with an anime Matrix LED array so you
can showcase your inner geek to the
World featuring a 16x10 aspect ratio QHD
Pantone validated Rog nebula display
this display not only looks great but
also offers unprecedented performance
thanks to his 240Hz refresh rate and 3
milliseconds response time with all that
power comes a full width heatsink
supported by Rog intelligent cooling
with tri-fan technology to keep the
laptop cool while intense gaming or
heavy workloads for more details check
out asus.com as I mentioned before the
s13 is pretty impressive and Asus has
really made some interesting design
choices here now looking at the design
and build quality the zamberg s13
features a revamped sophisticated finish
with a new lid design it really looks
sleek here with the Asus logo design
that has some simple lines action silver
and of course Asus has taken it a step
further by refreshing it with a new
Basalt gray color as well I like the
base of gray a lot it's Sleek it's
professional and like how the kind of
ceramic matte coating doesn't make this
lid a fingerprint magnet so what you're
going to notice immediately is how light
this laptop feels I mean Asus has opted
for a lightweight aluminum alloy for the
chassis and lid making this laptop about
a kilogram in weight so it feels
incredibly light in your hands to top it
off it's one centimeter profile check
that out
yeah this makes the laptop perfect for
everyday carry as it can fit practically
everywhere and anywhere and even comes
with this dual leather and fabric laptop
sleeve which is a nice touch just
slightly there as if it's Manila paper
man boom
and off we go now what's really really
about the zamboo s13 is this this is the
Ergo lift hinge so when you open up the
laptop the hinge actually lifts the
bottom of the chassis up a little bit
and provides more airflow underneath now
it also provides a more comfortable
typing position now on top of that the
Ergo lift does go all the way up to 180
degrees just to give you the option of
using the laptop as free as you can say
on your lap or flat on a table like this
just to give you varying degrees so that
if you do need to push the display a
little bit further or if you decide to
get the touchscreen option then putting
it on a flat table like so makes perfect
sense with the 180 degree hinge now the
keyboard on the Zenbook s13 is backlit
and you do get Chiclet Keys here as well
and it's surprisingly comfortable to
type on now from what Asus has mentioned
you do get 18.7 millimeters of pitch and
a one millimeter key travel for that
nice tactile feedback of the pressing
key so it really feels good it's as if
you're using a desktop PC keyboard if
you will now on top of that you do get
the Ergo sense touchpad and it's very
nice and very spacious and I love it so
much I personally like a larger touchpad
because I don't really use a mouse all
right especially if I'm traveling around
so it's really comfortable to just you
know click and like drag and hold for
like one corner screen to the next I
just love that I just love to do
everything just one stroke
yeah
now going over to the display here we
are seeing Asus going all out with OLED
displays with the entire range and line
up like the Zenbook 14x OLED VivoBook
OLED and zamboo 14 flip OLED so it's
really nice to see Asus keeping up in
this space now there is no doubt that
OLED panels well at least to me are much
sharper the color accuracy is there it's
more vibrant it's simply gorgeous and
the Zenbook s13 features that with a
13.3 inch 2.8 K display with display HDR
500 support and goes up to 550 nits Peak
brightness providing that immersive
viewing experience now having a 2.8 K
resolution display might be a downside
of course 4K resolution displays are
much sharper but you will be sacrificing
a lot more battery life just to have a
better display if you will and I think
Asus has made the right decision here to
kind of go in between
1080P 4K 2.8k right because it's a 13.3
and you don't need 4K you still get a
very good clean and sharp display thanks
to the OLED panel so it's going to be
perfect no matter what you do
performance wise the example s13 is
powered by the latest 13th generation
Intel i7 core processor specifically the
i7 1355u running at 10 cores 12 threads
up to 5 gigahertz with a thermal design
power TDP of up to 15 watts and a Max
boost of up to 55 Watts now that makes
it a speedy machine without chewing up
so much battery life and it also comes
with up to two gigabytes of LP ddr5 Ram
ensuring that it can handle heavy
multitasking with ease now the laptop
also features a one terabyte pcie nvme
4.0 SSD storage providing it quick boot
times and snappy performance now the
zamboo s13 comes with a decent selection
of ports including two Thunderbolt 4
USBC ports that can each support up to
40 gigabytes per second data bandwidth
you also can double as a display port
and also power delivery now it also
offers a full-size HDMI 2.1 port a USB
3.2 Gen 2 type a port and an audio combo
Jack so Asus has made sure that you can
easily connect to an external 4K display
additional storage devices and even
expand your connections and of course
with performance comes the battery life
and it's pretty much the most important
aspect of an Ultrabook and the s13
really delivers the s13 comes equipped
with a 63 watt hour battery and that's
about 10 to 13 hours of battery life and
of course this depends on how power
hungry your apps are and it also varies
on what type of workloads you're working
with but with that as the team provides
more than enough battery life to cover
at least a day of work and play so
that's pretty much the example s13 OLED
in a nutshell and if you're serious
about maximizing productivity while
staying on the go then the Zenbook s13
is an excellent choice anyway if you are
interested in getting one we have a more
detailed review in our website links in
the description below thank you guys so
much for watching and don't forget to
hit that subscribe button if you want to
see more videos just like this we'll see
you on the next one
thank you